for many Americans to protest about
police brutality and systemic racism are
a reminder that we have been here before
as part of tonight's CBS News special
we're calling it justice for all i sat
down with the mother of amadou diallo
you may remember this story back in 1999
Diallo a 23 year old immigrant from West
Africa was shot and killed by four New
York City police officers at his
apartment building
they fired 41 shots amadou diallo was
unarmed then Mayor Rudy Giuliani at the
time called the shooting a great tragedy
well in the years since his death his
mother's become an activist working to
improve relations between police and the
community she told me that hearing the
news of George Floyd's death felt like
she was reliving what happened to her
son at the end of his life he is calling
out for his mama
and every mother heard him we hear him
we did we had George Freud's we hear him
Caria to Diallo was pained when she
heard about the death of George Floyd as
the mother of Amadou Diallo having to
suffer my loss On February 14 1999 my
wound was open again on a busy corner of
the Bronx a street sign signals a story
from another time one that shook New
York to its core the last time we spoke
was on January 31st 1999 they say mom
I'm so happy he said I have finally
saved enough money and I'm going to
college and he was so proud of himself
absolutely
four days later Carrie Otto's phone rang
again it was a relative they said it was
shooting and then they say was by the
police I dropped the phone police said
they were searching for a rape suspect
and came upon Diallo thinking he was
reaching for a gun they opened fire for
white officers
five foot six 150 pound Amadou 41 shots
turns out he was unarmed he was reaching
for a wallet the problem was reaching
for a gun is a perception they saw this
black man in the vestibule he had no
criminal record
he never even have a traffic ticket in
New York City retelling this story today
is breaking my heart I'm sure because
Amadou was this young generous person
when you see him when you have chance to
meet my child
mrs. Diallo I'm so sorry it's breaking
all of our hearts hearing this story
again I have to say I was very touched
by her there's something about hearing a
mother say when you meet my child if you
knew my child when she's talking about a
grown-up that touched me in a very
special way it is heartbreaking we
should also tell you that all four
officers involved in amadou diallo death
were ultimately acquitted of
second-degree murder charges and Tony
the thing that stuck out to me she had
never spoken to the media before so
imagine what it was like in 1999 you get
off this plane to Africa
you're shoved in front of TV cameras and
she said I just wanted people to know my
son he was not he was described as a
street peddler she said he spoke five
languages
he was well-traveled he was working a
bunch of odd jobs to go to college and
he had just raised $9,000 so she wanted
people to understand the narrative of
who her son was she described as a
dreamer as a dreamer yeah the context is
everything here we are just over two
weeks from the death of George Floyd
she's 21 years from the death of her son
you can see it's still with her and it's
a reminder as we see people protesting
in the streets today that there is a
long long river of loss on this story
and that's why there's a big effort
today to finally put an end to it Gail
yeah because many people feel things
really haven't changed so much the
primetime special as I told you we're
calling it justice for all airs tonight
at 10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS